[Music]
so there was this teenager who got stuck
dangling from California's highest
bridge while filming a stunt recently oh
my stunt is you're a I didn't know we
had the highest we had a highest
bridge you win you dumb ass that's the
news [__] Tik Tok yeah more than 20
First Responders rescued the 19-year-old
you know how much that
costs that yeah that is no no no no
instant Jewish
money I could just see someone doing the
city budget where were these paramedics
for 3 hours he all in one place most
people don't even think about that right
yeah most people don't even realize like
when when people get evaced out or hel
like helic back man that [__]
costu really 20 people all holding sides
of a
parachute F under the bridge so who pays
for that him we all do we do
tax money we pay for people's dumb
people just vote like if the helicopter
shows up we go wait wait wait wait we
don't want to pay we don't want to pay
and they're like sorry you're going to
have to die's a they don't want to
pay right he did it to himself let him
die that's what I would say the
19-year-old was left swinging in the
breeze 700 ft above the North Fork
American River after he got stuck while
filming the stunt with friend is that in
Sacramento that's in San Francisco I
believe what does that mean left swing
[__] got up there himself he
left himself swinging the nobody left
you swinging you climbed up there you
dummy yes that he is a dummy y it is uh
the highest spin uh yeah what is it but
more than 21 responders were called to
the scene as a helpless team dangled
from the Forest Hill Bridge the highest
Span in California and fourth highest in
the US this is a [__] high what was
he doing like bungee jumping I hope he
was dangled upside down a stunt or
something honestly after the 18th
highest bridge does it matter you're
[__] dying if you fall damn why they
got to put that in
it's impressive it's in the breeze he's
dangling in the breeze it's like some
kind
of his friend dangling off a bridge like
no I'm not I'm sitting in a [__]
chair left in the breeze dude his friend
who filmed the entire incident called
the Emergency Services after became app
parent the team was stuck I love it he
was like I'm going to are you okay no
help I'm going to keep filming though
how do I keep the live but also pull up
the phone yeah I if I go to 911 it
cancels the video so can you get your
phone
[Laughter]
out it took the combined efforts of more
than 20 First Responders from Placer
County Sheriff's Office as well as the
local California Department of for stre
and Fire Protection to rescue the
19-year-old Daredevil they call him
Daredevil no pause Daredevil is a
[__] superhero Daredevil can see
[__] sound and [__] like that dummy
up on and he's a lawyer and he's a
lawyer Daredevil oh yeah that's right I
was like 19y old Matt Murdo
[__] a lawyer did the First
Responders just get him off by tasing
his dumbass [__] bridge then they
caught him in the parachute hey but was
it D devil like a thing like evil
coneval and all these guys that did
crazy stunts and it was like sanctioned
like it was like an event right with
competency yeah and they practiced it
yes so why would this be a daredevil it
just sounds like a dumb kid yeah he's a
dumbass we got lower
standards maybe he's really smart maybe
he's not you think he just calculated
the physics by a small margin a very
large he was obviously calculating the
physics with a 17-year-old cameraman
friend using an iPhone dam is there any
footage pictures a I have a photo yes
let's watch the failure 17-year-old
camera man you ain't no man you a child
camera
child camera kid that's a good idea
that's a good new this is about the best
I got if you can tell oh [__] he's not
even in shape enough wa they're coming
to get him oh wait hold up I thought he
was dangling by his [__] hands
sitting he's just sitting there in a
[__]
harness like a little [__] you could
literally walk up the you could walk up
the steel bars he's not in shape enough
weak Let Them Fall so he's just stuck in
a harness first first respond today I'd
be like all right climb up he's like
what climb up you're staying here
tonight just ask what do you think you
want to do here like what's your choice
what's your plan let's see let's see
your plan in motion
I want to know what the stunt was
supposed to be neither teen was charged
following the incident charge
trespassing for sure them up for Life
some cities they some cities they'll
charge you for wasting tax dollars yeah
if you get yourself in a predicament
they'll charge you for wasting tax it's
not like he fell off of a cliff yeah we
need a Jewish guy there calculating the
cost of all the responders and stuff and
then being like he here's a reasonable
amount that you got to pay back cuz it's
worth it unreasonable
amount no no I'm reasonable amounts if
you do reasonable [__] you run a stop
sign nobody gets hurt reasonable
amount I
would you climbed to the top of
America's fourth highest bridge that's
not a reasonable thing to do you be
became an unreasonable amount of money
you dumb [__] because an
unreasonable number of 20 [__] grown
men that could have been preventing
[__] murders stopping rapists in
their tracks intending to pregnant women
that were falling off of other
Bridges and your [__] was just hanging
there doing a whole lot of nothing for
TI Tok rescuing you were inconvenienced
for several hours I think these kids
need to pay a Big Bill until like for 10
years yeah yeah I want the bill to just
ruin their [__] lives not even funny
anymore more than student loans you know
yeah way high we should all be in office
this is good I'm V I'm running for mayor
of
California well mayor of California body
did it hey look at
me he's the governor hey look at me oh
Governor right the governor Oh I thought
it was California City in Nevada yeah oh
that place I think so is that where
prostitutes are legal I think so Jared
let's go I'm not into it aren't they
trying to make more brothel legal in
like Las Vegas like probably I think all
of Nevada except for Clark County you
say brothel are why would I want to wear
condom Mike who says condoms have to be
involved it's a prostitute man yeah I
want to like kiss her go down on her you
can
doers I did it get oh my God you went
down on a prute of course you went down
on the multiple times you got remember
that all over the place you went down on
a prostitute I [__] up my I love how
are the awesome hey can you tell some
stor the of people stupid [__] ass
little kid let him hang tell us your
prostitute story again you also but it's
worth it it's worth it do you use the
herpy cream or the anti
viral I
went my friend bought me a birthday
present and he didn't tell me what it
was drove me to the place it was a sheep
it was a strip mall okay that's so we go
in there and I'm just like okay we're
going to get massages consumer
electronics and he's giggling the whole
time and we sit down Mike this kind of
haveen you a lot of beautiful women pop
out I haven't had sex in like 6 months
and
then it was a wonderful time I but I
could I had to make love to her cuz I'm
not that kind of guy was no I feel you
yeah that's why I'm saying it's I picked
up I picked the hottest one cuz the
other one like or there was like six of
them five of them were like grandmas oh
hot oh not
yeah yeah whatever and one girl was hot
the grandmothers have the experience I
know I I should have known that I know
that now I touch my dick a lot [__]
you're going to touch my dick you better
have some miles under your pH and they
could have got like this you know hell
yeah girl but Dentures
Dentures so you this was a a fake
massage that a jerk off no it was full
everything they [__] wash you and
everything and I was just like this is
in America in America this was
completely shocked where where in
America tell jar and she just like while
she's Wasing it she's like so you don't
have any scds right she says yeah just
like anyone check in just yeah just like
anyone would
that's what they do they they
scientifically research that she [__]
people for a living yep doesn't ask any
of them if they have any STDs you like I
should go down on we [__] made out
like we were boyfriend and
girlfriend serious right now y he's
serious and
then I went from there and I just
went and then she didn't stop me and I
went all the way from the mouth down yep
no okay no no humor
me
did she seem like she was acting or was
she like damn your girl's getting some
[__] tonight time for I don't know I was
in my own mind I was having a good time
one thing led to another [__] you know
and then I came too fast too fast that's
thing too fast really no it was one of
those things where I was like so excited
I was doing all that stuff and then um
she put a condom on me with her mouth
and I was like oh my goodness and I was
like I'm about to go and she goes wait
she put it in and I was just I was bagio
water show as soon as great so fast and
she was laughing and then I had to I
have to wait in the waiting room cuz my
friend wasn't finished and I was just
sitting there and then uh another client
sat down she goes you you two make
friends make friends and I'm all like
this Armenian dude sitting in here with
me and I'm all like so you you go to
these things often he goes oh they're
all good bro they're all they're all I
want to talk to any other [__]
clients we're all degenerate losers I
don't want to be speaking it's like hey
you're in Hell talk to other demons like
no
[Laughter]
thanks what are you in here for how is
it going and I'm I'm just like where the
[__] is my friend and I'm just sitting
there and then those was all these girls
that finished their shift they come in
they're like giggling and then they're
like sitting right next to us they bust
out a lunch box and they start having
lunch the [__] and then me and him were
just looking at
and then he's like smoking a cigarette
and I'm just like waiting and I'm just
like this is so weird so [__] weird
and then I'm like all right he's done
and then we leave and I'm just laughing
the whole [__] time going home what
does the store say on the outside like
the sign sex like massage oh say massage
yeah what a [__] lie it was a strip
mall in Baldwin Park that's all I'm
going to say jar write that down but the
but the thing is it's crazy it was like
a food for less or something next to it
it was just like a regular wow like a
legit strip and when you go in there's
like a regular waiting room like a
dentist office [__] and then you go into
like not looking at teeth there's like a
waiting room another one with like like
a acupuncture thing and like a like a
bed with like a like a wax thing and I
was just like do you have to say a code
word so them for them to know he
arranged everything I have no [__]
clue what happened I bet the arranging
was like hey my budddy you're coming for
sex later they're like yeah see you at
12 yeah you're booked we'll see you cese
accent though yeah see you at 12
yeah regular that cuz the uh the the
mamasan lady she was like oh he has a
girlfriend here and I'm all like a
girlfriend girlfriend yeah no that
lady's not your girlfriend but no she
called her his girlfriend cuz she's
that's
his customer so he's yeah and then he
giggled away and he went over there and
then he's all like have fun and I was
just like
what the [__] is happening I'm like
initiation I was like well I'm here and
I never did anything like this before
and I'm not out I'm not going to run
where's the logic on that one I'm going
to go down and lick her
[Music]
[__]
for